I just got married so that's big yeah I
know why you're so young I get a lot of
that yeah you're fresh-faced kid at 43
why rush in when you know you know
that's what I'm saying I don't
understand men who [ __ ] about being
married you know most of like male
comedians like Oh married it's like do
you recognize the fact that you're
wearing a hockey jersey and basketball
shorts you pile of crap like you're no
prize man men always think they're so
amazing I thought what were you missing
out on were you gonna be taking like a
platinum cigarette boat through oceans
of hot tail I don't think you were
Trevor I think that was gonna happen
like my wife's the best thing that ever
happened me in my life man like I love
her so much she's the best thing ever
happened me and she's a jerk she's so
mean man I called her Donna Rickles
she's got so many zingers like remember
that kid you grew up with that like we'd
knock you in the crotch and you would
laugh I married that guy
like wait we're having dinner with
another couple whom I did not know and
this gal was like you guys gonna have
kids and the wife looks at me he goes oh
no kind of want a kid with a chin I'm
right here I love you that was a hot
burn good one good one my name is Matt
Braunger she calls me fat donger that's
for real yells it across IKEA donger fat
donger everyone turns guy next to me is
like your name is fat donger boy he's
like yep just walk away let the donger
legend grow she's the first woman to
ever call me bro I don't know why that
stings but it does right like that's a
free one for you ladies there's his guy
leaves messing with you hitting on you
in a bar or someone yelling at your work
just wait for them to run esteem be like
you've done bro it'll burn his ass
and she picked the right time to debut
that particular chestnut rose like you
gotten out of that party want to have
sex she's like on my period sorry bro
let's see that left hook coming yeah
just good at it that way we're all alone
I can just admit something privately
right now yeah okay great I am not good
at weed not good
I know it's amazing out there right now
and like I just I can't I've been
practicing the dojo my whole life cannot
get past the white belt ken huh like I
started early like how old were you
first time you got high eighteen you're
18 now don't say anything all right Andy
how old are you first time you got high
probably 16 16 that's nine years old
fourth grade thanks Portland Oregon went
over this kid Jeff's house he's in fifth
grade much cooler Jeff had what you call
cool parents which just means bad
parents that's all that means don't be
too cool of a dad man don't be that
dad's just like what are you ten now
grab a beer I don't want one dad dad
screw that call me rusty that kids not
growing up right Rou hurted Jeff's dad's
house man he there had jars of twisted
joints on the shelves like Lord of the
Rings pickles just everywhere within
child's reach so we used our child
reaches to pull one down and we got high
and all I remember is we were crying
laughing over the idea of sending
someone a Domino's Pizza box with no
pizza in it
like what a great prank like this was
great uh but wait it makes you laugh at
anything
but now you can bespoke your high you
can walk into like a legal weed store
and be like yeah I want to feel like
road warrior but relaxed right this way
sir
right this way and my thing is I want to
be cool
resist that young people all right like
I if there's someone cool and young and
they hand me one I'll take it like I
worked on a show that was set in a
dispensary and after we raft everyone
whipped out joints the size of baguettes
right and this young black millennial
the coolest of all Millennials don't
fight me was like hey man you smoked and
I was like yeah no I don't as I'm
reaching for it every cell in my body's
like no you're not good cuz for me to
take that dinosaur toe and smoke it it's
just like me walking past a skate park
at my age and being like gimme aboard
mom give me a skateboard you guys still
call this a halfpipe my neck like same
thing don't move me cuz I hit it it was
like cuz that's the thing about a weed
freak out it's inside no one knows
you're losing your mind right every
other drug you show the freak out acid
you rip your clothes off you're probably
peeing right cocaine you're bleeding
from the face like Reagan's still alive
come back weed you're just hanging out
no a good time yeah help me wrap me in a
blanket give me soup please someone kiss
my face like you're my mother please
thank you guys so much
[Applause]